SUPER SWEAT FOR, THAT’S FOR THE
TONIGHT’S ANGLE.
SOMETIMES NEWS HAPPENS SO FAST
THAT WE MISS THE OBVIOUS.
LIKE SIGNIFICANT FACTS BLOW
RIGHT BY US.
SUCH AS WHAT HAPPENED WITH THE
REPORTS OF THE PAST WEEKS ON THE
OUTGOING OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
’HIS ACTIONS TOWARDS THE
INCOMING TRUMP NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISOR MIKE FLYNN.
WE NOW KNOW THAT 39 OBAMA AIDES
SUBMITTED DOZENS OF UNMASKING
REQUESTS FOR CALLS THAT INVOLVED
FLYNN.
THE FIRST WAS MADE BY SAMANTHA
POWER ON NOVEMBER 30TH, 2016
WITH THE BULK BEING MADE BETWEEN
DECEMBER 14TH AND 16TH OF THAT
YEAR.
YET WHAT EVERYONE MISSED WAS
THAT THERE WERE NO -- WAS NO
UNMASKING REQUEST MADE FOR THE
CALL THAT SET THE CRIMINAL CASE
AGAINST FLYNN IN MOTION.
HIS DECEMBER 28TH, 2016, CALL
WITH RUSSIAN AMBASSADOR
SERGEY KISLYAK.
"THE INGRAHAM ANGLE" LEARNED
LATE LAST NIGHT FROM A
HIGH-RANKING SOURCE WITH DIRECT
KNOWLEDGE OF THAT SITUATION THAT
IT WAS THE FBI, NOT THE OFFICE
OF NATIONAL INTELLIGENCE, THAT
WAS MONITORING THE CALL.
"THE WASHINGTON POST" CONFIRMED
THIS TODAY.
IT WAS THE FBI, NOT THE NSA,
THAT WIRETAPPED KISLYAK’S CALLS
AND GREATER THE SUMMARY AND
TRANSCRIPT.
WHEN THE FBI CIRCULATED THE
REPORT, THEY INCLUDED FLYNN’S
NAME FROM THE BEGINNING BECAUSE
IT WAS ESSENTIAL TO
UNDERSTANDING ITS SIGNIFICANCE.
THERE WERE THEREFORE NO
REQUESTS, WE CAN CONCLUDE, FOR
THAT UNMASKING ABOUT
INFORMATION.
OKAY.
THUS IT WAS JIM COMEY’S FBI THAT
HAD THE CALL TRANSCRIPT.
NOW, THAT CERTAIN FIGURES WITHIN
THE FBI IN CONSULTATION WITH
FIGURES HIGHER UP IN THE
ADMINISTRATION CONSIDER THE
TRANSCRIPT POTENTIALLY, I DON’T
KNOW, A SECOND INSURANCE POLICY
AGAINST THE NEW ADMINISTRATION?
OR MAYBE THEY THOUGHT IT COULD
BE WEAPONIZED IF FLYNN WAS ASKED
ABOUT IT LATER, A FEW DAYS
LATER, AND LIED.
WE ARE BOUND TO FIND OUT MORE.
CONSTERNATION WAS BUILDING IN
THE OBAMA RANKS IN DECEMBER,
2016, AND INTO THE NEXT MONTH.
WE KNOW THIS.
THEY NEVER THOUGHT TRUMP WAS
GOING TO WIN THE WHITE HOUSE AND
THEY WERE ABOUT TO TURN THE KEYS
OVER TO TRUMP, A MAN, TO THEIR
HORROR, ABOUT TO UNDO ALMOST
EVERYTHING OBAMA HAD DONE ON
FOREIGN AND DOMESTIC POLICY.
NOW, I’VE SEEN MANY IN THE
NEVER-TRUMP WORLD SCOFF AT ANY
SUGGESTION THAT THERE WAS
ANYTHING IMPROPER IN THESE
FLURRY OF UNMASKING REQUESTS
THAT WERE FILED IN THOSE FINAL
WEEKS OF THE OBAMA ERA.
YET I THINK IT’S WRONG TO FOCUS
ON THE UNMASKING ITSELF, WHICH
IS LEGAL.
FOR YEARS, DEEP STATE LACKEYS
LIKE CLAPPER AND BRENNAN CLAIMED
FLYNN’S CALL WAS SCOOPED UP
INCIDENTALLY AS IF IT HAPPENED
ALMOST JUST BY ACCIDENT.
>> WHAT EXACTLY IS GOING ON WITH
THIS ENGAGEMENT WITH OUR PRIMARY
ADVERSARY, THE RUSSIANS?
THAT’S I THINK WHY THE WARNING
LIGHTS ON EVERYONE’S DASHBOARD
WAS ON.
IT WASN’T A SPECIFIC CONCERN
ABOUT MIKE FLYNN.
>> OBAMA OFFICIALS WERE GOING
OUT AND SAYING GIVING ME
EVERYTHING ABOUT MICHAEL FLYNN,
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
>> Laura: INTERESTING EXCUSE,
BUT WE KNOW THAT YOU’RE FULL OF
IT.
EVEN BEFORE WE HEARD FROM THAT
HIGH-LEVEL SOURCE LAST NIGHT,
RECENTLY DECLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS
SHOWED OBAMA AIDES MADE ZERO
UNMASKING REQUESTS.
THEY MADE THE DAY OF FLYNN’S
CALL WITH KISLYAK, SO THEY
DIDN’T MOVE TO UNMASK THAT CALL.
ON THE CONTRARY, FLYNN -- WE SEE
IT WASN’T JUST SWEPT UP, WASN’T
INCIDENTAL.
FLYNN WAS TARGETED.
AND SPECIFICALLY HE WAS TARGETED
BY JIM COMEY’S FBI.
AGAIN, FLYNN HAD EVERY RIGHT TO
TALK TO THE RUSSIAN AMBASSADOR.
HE HAD EVERY RIGHT TO DISCUSS
ANY ASPECT OF POLICY AND ANY
SUGGESTIONS THAT THE LOGAN ACT
WAS SOMEHOW A LEGITIMATE CONCERN
OF THE OBAMA PEOPLE IS JUST
PREPOSTEROUS.
FLYNN WASN’T FREELANCING FOR
SOME PRIVATE ENTITY AGAINST
AMERICAN INTERESTS.
HE WAS REPRESENTING THE NEW
ADMINISTRATION, FOR GOODNESS
SAKE.
RECENTLY RELEASED DOCUMENTS SHOW
THAT ON JANUARY 4TH 2017, THE
DOJ MOVED TO CLOSE ITS
INVESTIGATION OF FLYNN AFTERWARD
FOUND NO DEROGATORY INFORMATION
WITH RESPECT TO HIS RUSSIAN
CONTACTS.
YET FBI AGENT PETER STRZOK
INTERVENED TO REQUEST THAT THIS
INVESTIGATION REMAIN ACTIVE AND
HE INTERJECTED THAT IT WAS THE
SEVENTH FLOOR THAT WAS INVOLVED.
NOW, THE SEVENTH FLOOR?
THAT’S A EUPHEMISM FOR SENIOR
LEADERSHIP.
A.K.A., JIM COMEY.
THE NEWLY DECLASSIFIED MEMO
WRITTEN BY SUSAN RICE TO
HERSELF -- WHO DOES THAT, ON
INAUGURATION DAY, 2017, THAT
PURPORTS TO DOCUMENTS A
JANUARY 5TH 2017 WHITE HOUSE
BRIEFING THAT TOOK PLACE FOR
PRESIDENT OBAMA WITH
DIRECTOR COMEY, THE DEPUTY AG
SALLY YATES, VICE PRESIDENT
BIDEN AND SUSAN RICE.
NOW, THE MEMO ITSELF IS A
CLASSIC WASHINGTON MOP UP
OPERATION, HENCE SUSAN RICE’S
NICKNAME.
WANTED EVERY ASPECT OF THE
INVESTIGATION HANDLED BY THE
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT HANDLED BY THE
BOOK.
HE STRESSED HE WASN’T ASKING FOR
ANYTHING TO BE INITIATED FROM A
LAW ENFORCEMENT PERSPECTIVE AND
THEN REITERATED AGAIN THAT
EVERYTHING BE DONE BY THE BOOK.
THEN, AGAIN, IN THIS MEMO, COMEY
WAS ASKED BY THE PRESIDENT IF
THEY SHOULD WITHHOLD SENSITIVE
INFORMATION RELATED TO RUSSIA.
THE DIRECTOR REPLIED
POTENTIALLY.
EVEN THOUGH HE HAD NO INDICATION
THUS FAR THAT FLYNN HAD PASSED
CLASSIFIED INFO TO KISLYAK.
ALTHOUGH HE DID NOTE THAT THE
LEVEL OF COMMUNICATION WAS
UNUSUAL.
THERE’S ONLY ONE WAY HE WOULD
KNOW THAT, RIGHT?
SPYING.
IN HER MEMO, RICE WROTE THAT
DIRECTOR COMEY AFFIRMED THAT HE
WAS PROCEEDING BY THE BOOK AS IT
RELATES TO LAW ENFORCEMENT.
NOW, THE PHRASE, "BY THE BOOK"
WAS USED THREE TIMES IN THAT
MEMO.
ONE MEMO, USED THREE TIMES.
SEEMS LIKE SUSAN RICE WAS
SWIFFERING UP ANOTHER OBAMA
MESS.
THE PHRASE "HE DOTH PROTEST TOO
MUCH" COMES TO MIND.
THEY ARE PROCEEDING BY THE BOOK
IF PROCEEDING BY THE BOOK MEANS
POTENTIALLY WITHHOLDING
SENSITIVE INFORMATION RELATED TO
NATIONAL SECURITY TO THE
INCOMING NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISOR, WITHOUT ANY
JUSTIFICATION WHATSOEVER.
NOW, THE BOTTOM LINE, COMEY AND
PETER STRZOK DIDN’T LIKE AND
THEY DIDN’T TRUST FLYNN, WHO
OBAMA HAD FIRED YEARS EARLIER.
AND THEY FELT THE SAME ABOUT THE
MAN WHO WAS ABOUT TO BE SWORN IN
AS PRESIDENT.
THEY REVILED TRUMP.
THIS ENTIRE EPISODE SHOULD BE
BOTH TERRIFYING AND ENRAGING FOR
ALL AMERICANS WHO THINK THE FBI
SHOULD OPERATE TO KEEP US SAFE
WITHOUT POLITICAL BIAS.
AND ONE MORE LITTLE THING HERE.
LOOK CLOSELY AT THE DECLASSIFIED
MEMO.
THE TIME-STAMP IS 12:15:32.
15 MINUTES AND 32 SECONDS AFTER
SUSAN RICE IS NO LONGER NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISOR IN 15 MINUTES
AND 32 SECONDS INTO THE TRUMP
PRESIDENCY.
THIS IS ALL WEIRD, RIGHT?
IT’S ALL REMINISCENT OF ANOTHER
RESCUE MISSION THAT SHE TOOK IT
UPON HERSELF TO COMPLETE AFTER
BENGHAZI.
IN 2012, SUSAN RICE WAS DIRECTED
TO GO ON NATIONAL TELEVISION AND
BLAME THE VIDEO FOR THE ATTACK
ON OUR COMPOUND THAT RESULTED IN
THE DEATH OF OUR AMBASSADOR AND
THREE OTHERS.
SHE DID HER DUTY.
REPEATING AND IMPLAUSIBLE IN
WHAT TURNED OUT TO BE FALSE
NARRATIVE.
>> THERE WAS A VIOLENT PROTEST
OUTSIDE OF OUR EMBASSY SPARKED
BY THIS HATEFUL VIDEO.
>> THE SPONTANEOUS REACTION TO
WHAT HAD JUST TRANSPIRED HOURS
BEFORE WHICH WERE PROMPTED OF
COURSE BY THE VIDEO.
SPONTANEOUS REACTION TO WHAT HAD
JUST TRANSPIRED IN CAIRO AS A
CONSEQUENCE OF THE VIDEO.
>> Laura: IT WAS A TERROR
ATTACK THAT TOOK PLACE A COUPLE
OF MONTHS BEFORE THE
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION IN 2012.
NOT EVEN A COUPLE OF MONTHS.
BUT LET’S GET BACK TO THE FLYNN
AFFAIR.
NOW, WHAT HAPPENED BETWEEN
JANUARY 5TH AND INAUGURATION DAY
THAT SPOOKED SUSAN RICE INTO
TYPING THAT MEMO INTO GOVERNMENT
COMPUTERS?
A MEMO ABOUT A MEETING THAT’S
TAKEN PLACE MORE THAN TWO WEEKS
EARLIER.
NOW TODAY SHE CLAIMS THROUGH A
SPOKESPERSON, OF COURSE, THAT
THE WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL HAD
INSTRUCTED HER TO DO THIS.
WHY?
IS THERE ANOTHER DOCUMENT THAT
WE HAVEN’T SEEN YET DIRECTING
PETER STRZOK TO KEEP THE FLYNN
OPERATION GOING?